you know we were just chatting seconds
before uh the we were gonna roll on the
podcast and we realized we should
include this in the story but uh you
famously uh depicted a gentleman named
Andy Bernard and then I realized oh uh I
I knew the real Andy Bernard because uh
Greg Daniels who uh you know created the
American office
um and a dear old friend of yours yes we
go way back we were writing Partners
together and uh he's we we remained
friends to this day he likes to take
walks
um he tires quickly so I always bring a
wheelbarrow sure and you can just lie in
it and he needs marshmallows uh and I
continue pushing us both because I'm so
strong uh
but that's neither here nor there Greg
uh named uh had a good friend who uh
named Andy Bernard so he named uh your
character Annie Bernard and uh I was in
the same dorm as Andy Bernard freshman
year of college same entryway uh and I
remembered he stuck out to me very nice
very nice person but I think he was the
first person who I saw had a computer on
his desk it was an Apple computer
whatever they would have had in 1980
probably had two years yeah yeah well
that's that was our first that was the
first computer in my house me too yeah
in school yeah well it's it's funny to
me because I didn't think much about it
at the time I just thought oh that's wow
look at that thing that's cool
um I had uh a uh I think it's called a
selectric typewriter that had a took a
cartridge what do you mean
it's what I had in high school and when
it was time to go to college there was
no I'm getting a computer but what kind
of car what do you mean I had a
cartridge yeah
no what happened was instead of a ribbon
you slid a cartridge into the side that
was the ribbon you typed away on it then
when you made a mistake you ejected that
cartridge and you put a different
cartridge in that had white out on it
and you rewrote it then you ejected that
cartridge uh it was a um so much work it
was a [ __ ] Brown uh computer uh and
electric and typewriter typewriter I'm
sorry I called it a computer
yeah it's so cute I used to tell I used
to bring women up to the room ago would
you like to see my computer
[Music]
now question about just this is a
technical question about your uh your
typewriter did it was it so so I
remember when typewriters went went from
the little the little like metal uh
things that would thwap the paper right
and they would they there was like this
major evolutionary step to where it was
a little ball it was a ball okay yeah
exactly what I did not have the ball it
had the metal things that shot up it was
electric powered but the flappers the
flappers if we're gonna get technical
they were the slap yes my computer had
swappers uh anyone just tuning in very
confused and uh
but it is this generation gap because
um then Flash Forward to uh to Greg and
I a couple years later going out to Los
Angeles and working on a show called not
necessarily the news we had IBM I loved
that show oh oh great okay well we uh we
that was our first we cut our teeth on
that job we were 22 we we got this job
writing gags for that show and those
were the electric typewriters that had
the little ball and
um we were on those then we went to
Saturday Night Live and went back in
time they didn't there wasn't there
weren't typewriters or computers 1988
there were legal pads no everyone wrote
on legal pads and then we submitted our
scripts to a steno pool oh my God uh oh
my God and they would keep they would
come to us I had they liked me because I
have a very precise handwriting
um uh and so does Greg Daniels Robert
Smigel Odenkirk I think less so Robert
would scroll and so they would come up
to us and we would work together on
sketches and they would find me in the
hall and go what is this and I'd say oh
uh that says decapitate uh right
you're translating smigels yes like
scribbles and Scrolls uh but anyway it's
so fascinating to me now that
I try to when I talk to my kids
I sound like a guy that listened to
Franklin Roosevelt on a curve top radio
well you did say the words Steno pool
to me that takes like
that that just yeah that's like you were
right like was everything black and
white yeah do you want a minute
we did not long after there were color
televisions we did we had a black and
white TV my father thought it was a
waste of money so
um we had a black and white TV until
1977 which when you think about it
that's a long time there are color TVs
available everywhere in like 1963 64.
earlier actually and
a lot of people had them so I was
watching Star Trek I was watching all
these shows
and I had no idea that the uniforms were
different colors I thought it was all
just a well it was a very depressed
Starship and they're all wearing these
different Grays and then we went to our
uh I went to a friend's house
and Star Trek came on and my eyeballs
exploded because girl's shirt is like a
bright vibrant yellow yeah gold gold
yeah and I had no idea
um the rods and cones in your eyeballs
were just like going off yeah they're so
excited they were so excited it was my
first orgasm yeah
I was standing there looking at a color
it was can we say I was at my friend's
house can we call it an igasm
I mean I am I'm a dad how about an eye
gas and that led to an orgasm I'm gonna
make it I'm gonna make a dad joke so
anyway it's just funny that uh I'm
amazed now because my experience of
college was when they would say it's got
to be a 10-page paper
I was there was fear am I gonna get to
the 10th page you didn't know until you
were done and if you finished at eight
you would then say yes
so what have we learned here yeah
exactly and so I repeat
uh Thoreau when he went to Walden Pond
and um it was just [ __ ] for two
pages to get there because you didn't
know uh and so I yeah these kids today
these Punk kids today you of course
you're you're much younger than I uh and
grew up with all the best technology and
uh I resent you for it yeah no I I had a
hoverboard as a kid
backs flying cars the whole my dad's a
robot
but a kindly robot no it's funny you
were saying how your dad held out on the
color TV because because it's sort of
like uh an Indulgence yes to have why
who needs a color in your television
right my dad was my dad took watching
television so seriously that we were
ahead of the curve on like we had a we
had a big TV in our in our basement and
um
and we were like very early adopters of
cable television that's how and so I was
watching HBO as a little kid that's how
uh not what years was not necessarily
the news well I don't know when it
begins but I want to say it probably
started in maybe 83 or 84 or I think
Greg and I show up
in 85 we show up in late August of 85.
and this was back when if I wanted I
mean I don't think my parents had HBO so
uh no it didn't it didn't work on black
and white TV yeah I think you have to
check into and and also uh you'd have to
like check into a motel to watch my show
uh and uh
that's such a deep cut I love that the
name is yes well because every Hotel had
a sign HBO like we have HBO right that
was like on all you drive by all the the
motels you know what's a nice uh one of
them I love the movie uh No Country for
Old Men and there's such a great because
that movie takes place around 1980 and
there's such a great moment where
um Josh Brolin's character is thinking
about hiding out in this one motel and
it says out front we've got HBO
exclamation point yeah it just makes me
very happy because that's what HBO meant
to me that's what you watched when you
checked into a hotel yeah it's it's
mind-numbing to think how much things
have changed yeah you know exactly and
how many years were you guys on that I
think we were there from 85
uh through maybe 87 then we had a period
of unemployment they shrank the staff
they liked us but we were new hires and
and uh so we didn't make the cut and we
were uh
Greg got a job doing s.a.t prep for kids
and I got a job at Wilson's house of
Sweden leather
um
and I put that place on the map
Wilson's house of suede and leather yeah
is is Wilson is has swarthy and
misogynistic as he sounds
oh listen he doesn't disappoint well it
was a chain so I don't know who Wilson
was but it was uh I was the raking of
cigar smoke and Right Guard his skin is
leather his face is fine Corinthian
leather wow that's it yeah so uh but
we've talked enough about me I think we
should start to talk about you but then
talk more about me great uh I do I have
endless questions about the not
necessarily the news days oh and and on
the Andy Bernard tip too since we
started there I'll just say
I always knew Greg always told me that
he named the character after his friend
and I as the you know as the show went
on and Annie Bernard was a pretty toxic
fellow
um you know I I had I adored Andy
Bernard and and tried to like imbue him
with a lot of uh Pathos and Humanity
despite
um oh you know yeah some toxic
um inclinations and but I I often would
think like Greg this is kind of a kind
of a dick move like like is he is he
really your friend is this Andy Bernard
or are you is this your way of sort of
like taking out some frustrations with
him or and I think I he may have come to
set one time or maybe I just remember
Greg showing me a picture of him on set
and I just remember seeing a picture of
this very sweet looking guy in like he
couldn't be a nicer guy in like an LL
Bean parka or something on a hike and I
just was like what are you doing to this
poor man
Greg also had a friend named Dwight
Schrute in college brutal
and he called Ricky Gervais yeah
yeah Ricky met him briefly and and stole
it first